the ps plus lineup for march has been
announced more pokemon are coming to
sword and shield and more
following a leak march's playstation
plus lineup has been revealed and it
includes four games rather than the
three we've been getting most months
reported by d labs and later confirmed
by sony itself the march lineup of games
include the first person slasher from
505 games ghost runner which launched in
2020 for pc ps4 xbox one and nintendo
switch in 2021 for ps5 and xbox series x
and s the game follows the player in the
shoes of jack who must traverse
dangerous cyberpunk areas while
combating enemies and solving platform
puzzles alongside ghost runner sucker
punch studios ghost of tsushima legends
is also included the co-op and online
multiplayer mode that was released
following the campaign's launch for ps4
and ps5 also joining the collection is
team sonic racing which launched in 2019
it's a cart racing game and a spin-off
to the popular sonic the hedgehog series
which features 15 playable characters
from the franchise ark survival evolved
is included too if you're into something
that vaguely resembles horizon but isn't
horizon the ps plus games for february
which were also leaked included ea
sports ufc 4 planet coaster and tiny
tina's assault on dragon key
subscription holders will only have
until march to get their hands on these
three games before the next batch
arrives
pokemon sword and shield are making some
hard to find pokemon a little easier to
catch as part of this year's pokemon day
celebration you can now find gigantomax
versions of the original kanto starters
blastoise venusaur and charizard in the
wild area you'll have until february
27th at 3 59 pm pacific to catch them
the gigantomax kanto trio will appear in
pokemon dens and can be taken on with a
max raid battle to enable the battle
you'll need to connect your switch to
the internet and then select mystery
gift followed by get the wild area news
once you've done that the chances of
getting a gigantic max pokemon in a max
raid battle are significantly increased
normally the easiest way to get
gigantomax versions of the kanto
starters involves playing through the
isle of armor dlc and using a special
item to upgrade your starters this
method makes them much more easily
available whether you catch them or
defeat them you'll also get a max
mushroom which can be used in battle for
a big stat boost or out of battle to
craft max soup which also allows you to
gigantomax a compatible pokemon
2023's call of duty game may be delayed
to the following year this is the title
after what's expected to be modern
warfare and war zone 2 this year this
would mark the first time since 2004
that a year would pass without a new
mainline call of duty game which has
gotten new entries on an annual basis
since 2005's call of duty 2. as reported
by bloomberg activision blizzard is
delaying 2023's call of duty in hopes of
further polishing the game seeing as
microsoft has announced its intention to
continue developing activision
franchises for competing console
platforms that likely means we'll see
this new call of duty launch for xbox
series xns ps5 and pc the report also
says that activision blizzard is pushing
this new call of duty's release
following a recent game failing to meet
expectations no exact game is listed but
both vanguard and warzone underperformed
in 2021 in comparison to black ops cold
war and war zone in 2020 so it's likely
in reference to one of those
according to the report treyarch will
assist in developing an upcoming yet to
be announced free to play online game
that game will launch in 2023 filling
call of duty's slot however in a
statement an activision spokesperson
said we have an exciting slate of
premium and free-to-play call of duty
experiences for this year next year and
beyond reports of anything otherwise are
incorrect we look forward to sharing
more details when the time is right and
while experiences could refer to many
different cod related things we'll just
have to wait for official announcements
to know for sure
how would you feel about a year without
a new cod for the first time in almost
20 years let me know in the comments and
as always leave a like subscribe and
tune in tomorrow for your next gamespot
news
[Music]
you